do you remember all those pokemon stars  rumors well here's another to add to the  pile I'm Tony and this game spot news  update just might let you catch them all  a new job posting from developer Game  Freak is looking for employees for a  quote globally popular RPG that just  about anyone knows for console now I'm  no detective but I've got a hunch  they're talking about Pokemon add this  to the rumors about a Nintendo switch  version of pokemon sun and moon called  stars and you've got yourself quite an  interesting story be sure to subscribe  to gamespot to stay up to date as it  develops the original reports said  Pokemon stars is due out within six  months of the switches launch although  no release date can be confirmed until  the game itself is announced but for now  you can take a different journey to the  stars with our latest documentary the  story of mass effect  [Music]